Flipkart is a leading Indian e-commerce company.
Its mission statement was always in
Find ways to improve
Life experiences and lifestyles of Indian users
By offering the most suitable products at a price
The highest quality
For all user segments within the country
Using technology.
One of the most important lessons learned from the user base
Is that there are many devices containing
Memory capacity less than 1 GB, making customers cancel shopping tours
Because their phones do not meet storage or computing requirements
So we launched our Android Go app.
If the pages load more quickly,
I can provide this extra time to the user,
Which gives him a much better experience
During his shopping tour on Flipkart.
The space required to install the app according to the Android Go guidelines
Must be less than 40 MB.
With some good guidance from the Google team
This area has been reduced.
We use Android Studio Refractor and ProGuard
They are useful in reducing the volume
Resources and code base.
We also use WebP
Which gives us a reduction of 20%
In the size of the images download.
The instructions we received indicate that the size is relatively specific
Must be less than 50 MB.
So, we've made a lot of changes to resource allocation
In the code base.
We reduced the cache size from two to half screen.
We reduced the amount of temporary memory for bitmaps
From 4 screens to one screen.
By working on the Android Go app for Flipkart,
Our application has become much faster,
And best in performance.
And experienced the current user base
A 34% reduction in uninstallation rates.
The crash rate of newer application versions dropped
At a rate of ten times less than in older versions,
With an average rating of 4.4 or more.
We have reached this stage after much effort.
We're excited that with Android Go,
We will exceed 200 million downloads very soon
And very easily, because we believe
That the next group of users online
They will use Android Go devices
The appropriate mediator to deal with.
So if you are an app developer
Applications are designed for Indian users,
Understand user needs.
And tried to tailor technology to meet these needs.
You will then get an application
Admire users.